Speaker 1: All right. This next story is kind of
a mix of the gun story and also a 2022 story. I
don't know how many of you are aware of this. And
I want to be I want to be respectful and kind of
delicate with this story. But also it there's some
insanity going on. There's a guy named Herschel
Walker. Herschel Walker is running for Senate in
Georgia. Herschel Walker is endorsed by Donald
Trump. Herschel Walker is a former NFL football
player and there are now multiple clips of him
being I don't mean just slightly kind of loopy.
I'm talking about complete incoherence. Complete
incoherence when asked about what should be done
with regard to guns. Now, I don't man, what's
tough about this is I don't want to say this is
necessarily a story about mental illness, but
there are many reports about Herschel Walker that
he suffers from dissociative identity disorder,
that he has multiple personalities. So is there
possibly a mental illness component here? Yeah.
There is also the story or the allegation that
what we're talking about here is a brain injury
from football, that he has CTE, chronic traumatic
encephalopathy. But it also feels wrong to say
this is simply a brain injury because this guy
is a right winger either way. And in terms of
his ideas, he he has had terrible ideas for a
long time. So I think if we just say this is a
brain injury, we're also not we're also doing
a disservice. But take a look at these clips.
Manu Raju from CNN approached Herschel Walker
the other day and asked him, Do you think we
need new gun laws because of what happened in
Texas? And he said, what I like to do is see it
and everything and stuff. That. That's his answer.
Okay. This is the guy Trump endorsed and who won
his primary in Georgia.
Speaker 2: Hey,
why don't Rogers, U.S.A.? I know, but
are you just bringing new gun laws in
the wake of this Texas shooting? Do you
support new gun laws in the wake of.
Speaker 3: What I like to do, what I like to
see in in everything, in the stuff I like.
Speaker 2: To see it. You know,
I never knew Jared.
Speaker 1:
So he just kind of mumbles to himself.
I like to see it and walks away. This is
complete and utter incoherence. This guy
could be a senator and he would be a senator
on the backs of Republican votes. Here's an
interview he gave yesterday morning to Fox News
and he said that a possible solution to
school shootings would be a department
that can look at young men. That's looking
at women. That's looking at social media.
Take a listen.
Speaker 3: See, there is a person will in
that weapon, you know, Cain kill Abel, you know,
and that's a problem that we have. And I said,
what we need to do is look into how we can stop
those things. You know, he talked about doing a
disinformation. What about getting a department?
They can look at young men that's looking
at women. They're looking at social media. What?
Speaker 1: What about getting a department that's
looking at young men, that's looking at
women, that's looking at social media?
This could be one of 100 senators.
And I want to be sensitive to
the mental illness component, the brain injury
component. But this is just fundamentally
humiliating. This is the winner of the primary.
Speaker 3: About doing that, looking into
things like that. And we can stop that
that way. But yet they want to just.
Speaker 1: We can stop. What that way. What
would we stop with? A department that looks
at men looking at women, looking at social media?
What what on earth is that? It's like a strange
it's like those Russian matryoshka dolls of you've
got social media and then women look at that
and men look at the women looking.
What are you talking about, dude?
Speaker 3: Continue to talk about taking away your
constitutional rights. And and I think there are
more things we need to look into. This has been
happening for years. And the way we stop it,
by putting money into the mental health field, by
putting money into other departments rather than
department is we want to take away your rights.
Speaker 1: Dear God. So that's a Trump endorsed
Republican. You know, we went when Trump ran as a
Republican candidate, we said the Republican Party
would never be so dumb as to make this guy their
nominee. And they did. And then we said, okay,
but they're not going to be able to make this
guy president. And they did. And so we now see
Herschel Walker. We need a department that can
look at young men looking at women, looking at
social media. We see Herschel Walker saying what
he wants to do is see it in everything and stuff,
see it in everything, as he mumbles to himself as
he walks away and we say, well, they'll never make
him the Republican nominee. And they did. And now
we're sort of hoping they're not going to make him
one of 100 senators, are they? And we're not going
to know the answer to that until November. These
are really, really scary times. Let me know what
you make of it. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman